so I had the chickenpox and I was
obsessed with Rob he as everybody on the
planet was I was in a long line of
people who just loved you so much and
somehow you heard I got the chickenpox
and you called me
[Applause]
not for sure that my mom was playing a
trick on me in a really sweet way and
I'll never forget like the house we
lived in the phone I was on where I was
in the room I can picture the room where
it happened and we talked and and then
you invited me to your birthday party
that's right and I came and it was the
best night of my life you you you were
so great on the Dance Floor cutting it
up you were like like a little mini
Madonna
which is exactly what I was going yes
it was
it's just it makes me so happy because I
mean you're
tapestry your career in fact can we just
I can't even I gotta just skip it and
get straight to behind the scenes and
look and look at your life because it's
you have made so many incredible films
will you play behind the scenes I don't
play anything
this is somewhat of an origin story but
not because you you were around you had
done other things but like The Outsiders
yeah oh my God
okay so my behind the scenes on this
photo that's a very famous photo this
first cast photo of The Outsiders
Patrick Swayze is standing on bricks to
make himself look taller no yes yes I
was like oh that's a that's a pro baller
move
I like that well also he really was like
the patriarch figure he was Daryl you
were soda pop I was oh my God and there
was two-bit Johnny boy I mean yeah you
know a Ponyboy it was Johnny do it for
Johnny for Johnny
did you like I mean what was it like to
be with that group group a lot of
testosterone
a lot of testosterone I was eight I
turned 18 on the set
who is the naughtiest
oh see Thomas Howell the the Ponyboy the
youngest of all like the youngest was
the naughtiest and what year was this
82. okay because I had just done E.T
with him in 81. that's right I remember
you so it was my first movie first movie
ever and my first time away from home
almost like learning how to do my own
laundry at a laundromat
man Cruz and I rent a car oh my God
trying to figure out how to get our
jeans washed look at Tom Cruise
was he cool he's great so great
okay then another like societal
Awakening St Elmo's Fire
[Music]
first of all that hairdo I'm wearing
there's a lot of flammable material in
that hair that's all I can say what do
you remember from being on that set
[Music]
foreign